[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Mike Florio our good
buddy from pro football talk live and uh
football night in America let me start
with Sean Payton I threw it out last
week I said I wouldn't be surprised if
you just went back to TV here if he
surveyed all these jobs and went you
know what I'll take another year to kind
of see what's going to open up next year
where do you think we stand with Sean
Payton yeah I was told a couple of weeks
ago Dan it's 50 50 whether he coaches
this year or next year he hadn't done
any interviews yet and the reality is if
you don't coach this year you're not
going to make the money you would have
made coaching this year that goes away
and it never comes back but you've got
to find the right spot I think one of
the Practical impediments the four teams
interested in him all had entrenched
general managers and it is our human
nature to protect our backyard in come
Sean Payton with an inclination to take
over you necessarily have less juice as
the GM of the team that's been a very
real factor in all of this so when you
aren't getting perhaps the power you
thought you would get the money may not
be close to the 20 to 25 million dollars
we've heard attached to Peyton all the
way back to last year when the Dolphins
were ready to hire him and got busted
for tampering with him and Tom Brady
maybe you do wait a year maybe there is
no job that just screams out to you I've
got to have this job especially with a
possibility that the Charter's job maybe
comes open next year if there's another
failed season with Justin Herbert at
quarterback because I would imagine any
candidate wants that job if that job
comes open Dan Quinn going back is the
defensive coordinator with the Cowboys
what do you make of that move
well I suggested initially that he
decided to go back after he realized he
wasn't going to have an opportunity to
go anywhere else and I was told
privately that he wasn't out of it with
these other jobs he just decided it was
the right thing for him it just seems
odd to me and this is a point Peter King
made earlier today on our show the idea
that he would go through those
interviews distract himself at a time
when he should have been preparing for
the 49ers offense why go through that
Peter said the interview with the Colts
was four hours why go through that if
you really aren't interested in taking
the next step up and maybe he learned
something through the process where he
said I'm fine where I am maybe he's the
wink wink nod nod successor to Mike
McCarthy I don't know but it's just odd
to me when you go through the process
and don't wait for a final answer before
making your decision but then Mike
McCarthy said Jerry Jones once seemed to
coach as long as Tom Landry coached
maybe he met as long as Tom Landry
coached after Jerry Jones bought the
team
1985.
if he coaches as long as Landry did 85.
uh explain the Carolina situation here
with Frank Reich getting the job his
daughter was hired earlier by the
Panthers and then Steve Wilkes is on the
outside looking in well and let me start
there with Steve Wilkes the statement
that was issued by his lawyer yesterday
makes it clear that the Panthers are
going to be invited to the pending
lawsuit that has five or six teams
already joined in it with Brian Flores
Steve Wilkes and Ray Horton alleging
racial discrimination but the element
here will be that Steve Wilkes wasn't
hired in whole or in part because of the
fact that he joined
arm in arm with Brian Flores to stand up
to the shield yeah to say you have
Employment Practices that are wrong and
it's amazing how many people don't
realize it's illegal to hold that
against someone that's protected
activity under the law you have the
right to address grievances against your
employer in court and they can't hold it
against you they can't not choose you
for the head coaching job
for any reason tied to that and when you
look at Reich you look at Wilkes you
look at what Wilkes did
it the the Panthers had better be able
to explain persuasively why they chose
not to continue with Wilkes and here's
how reich's daughter factors into it
because it's not about nepotism
nepotism's Rife in the NFL but she
announced she was working for the
Panthers about 90 minutes after the
final game of the regular season on a
Sunday I guarantee you
that if and when the Panthers are joined
to this lawsuit still Steve Wilkes
lawyers will delve into every nook and
cranny emails text messages aggressive
deposition questioning when did you know
did you know did you know when she went
to work that Frank Reich was already
targeted because that goes to the whole
idea of the Sham interview the owners
know before they even start the process
who they're going to hire and all of the
interviews including the Rooney Rule
interviews or just check the box to
comply with League policy I know that
sometimes we don't let facts get in the
way with like Nathaniel Hackett getting
the job as offensive coordinator with
the Jets which obviously means that
Aaron Rodgers will then go to the Jets
right Mike anything to this well Dan I
firmly believe last year that the
Broncos when they hired Nathaniel
Hackett to be the head coach thought
they had a very good shot at Aaron
Rodgers and I don't think it was a
coincidence that just within an hour or
two after Rogers announced he was
staying with the Packers for 2022. the
Broncos had a deal in place for Russell
Wilson I think Rogers was plan a and
Wilson was Plan B so the Jets have come
out and said they're looking for a
veteran quarterback Aaron Rodgers
potentially is available it's not
something you just snap your fingers and
do you've got a huge tap number that's
got to be dealt with the Packers are
going to want something in trade first
Rogers has to decide he even wants to
play but obviously the presence of
Nathaniel Hackett would make the Jets
more desirable than they would be if he
wasn't there but there's a lot of
decisions Rogers has to make before he
even gets to the point where he's
assessing where he would play next year
if he plays for a different team I just
assumed last year he got to the brink
and decided I'm just staying in Green
Bay and I don't know why he wouldn't
just decide to stay in Green Bay this
year he's going to make nearly 60
million fully guaranteed if he says to
the Packers I'm here I'm staying deal
with me
Tom Brady was testy with Jim Gray but I
kind of viewed that maybe different than
most people I thought it's I'm going to
come out and be angry at my friend Jim
Gray just to let people know that I
haven't spoken to any other team right
now exactly
you're absolutely right first of all Dan
the the podcast is pre-recorded they
could have taken that part out right or
re-recorded it like hey ask me again
yeah he didn't even ask him what are you
going to do he said do you have a
timetable yeah Dan we saw what happened
last year he was going to Miami he and
Peyton were going to Miami
and then it all hit the fan and the
Dolphins lost a first round pick and
that was that I think this was his way
to throw everyone off the trail now that
he's talking to other teams they're
talking to him it's all tampering
violations he needs to be able to talk
to them now so he can make a decision in
March is Miami in play
with Brady
what's that Miami in play
from his perspective they're definitely
in play from the Dolphins perspective
they get very upset when you suggest
that because I think they don't want to
complicate to his ongoing recovery from
his latest concussion any more than they
already have by
giving any Credence to the idea that
they're looking for another quarterback
so I think the Dolphins are going to be
very quiet about it and they already got
stung last year with tampering but Brady
I believe is at least interested in
evaluating the possibility why wouldn't
he be they've they've got plenty of
pieces in place where he could go and
play play well and contend for a
championship explain what you were
hinting at with the title games maybe in
the future being played at neutral sites
or or on different days I think you said
Sunday or Monday like where are we
headed with the the potential for a
neutral site title game well there's
only so many places in the pizza that
the NFL can cram the cheese and there
are certain Revenue opportunities that
you can take advantage of without
increasing your cost by a single penny
and this whole neutral site thing for me
the moment Dan was last Friday
right about now when the league issued
this announcement of 50 000 tickets sold
in 24 hours to a neutral site bills
Chiefs game have to build season ticket
holders half to Chiefs season ticket
holders and I thought you know they're
telling us where this is going they're
doing their Victory lap preemptively so
we all understand that at some point in
the future there's going to be a push
for neutral side conference
championships they want the college big
game atmosphere when you tune in and
you've got sad reaction from Texas Fan
sad reaction from Alabama fan they're
all in the same place 50 50 in their
team's colors it doesn't happen at the
Super Bowl because that's a destination
you get your tickets before you even
know who's going hey I'm going to the
Super Bowl this year I don't care who's
in it I'm going to the Super Bowl
destination Conference Championship
means half the state like the old sitcom
premise where they put the tape down the
middle of the room that's what the NFL
is looking for and people hate it but
what's going to happen if they do it
we're gonna not watch it just like the
Sunday Monday possibility to split it up
because I'd love to just focus on 49ers
Eagles Sunday and then worry about
Bengals Chiefs Monday but fans don't
like it but if the NFL sees a way to
make more money doing it that way they
will
have a great weekend Mike thanks for
joining us That's Mike Florio pro
football talk live in the show that
precedes hours on peacock with Chris
Sims